DAN GALPIN: Hello.
I'm Dan Galpin for
"The Developer Show."
This is your weekly update
on the coolest developer
news from Google.
We recently introduced
support for digital goods
and subscriptions, as
well as Google sign-in
for the Assistant.
This will make it easier for you
to create a seamless purchasing
path across devices
and to better
personalize the experience for
your users on the Assistant.
For more details
and screenshots,
take a look at the post linked
in the description below.
The Google Cloud
Platform team recently
launched a dedicated
Kotlin portal
to help you more easily
find resources related
to Kotlin on Google Cloud.
Additionally, Google has
joined forces with JetBrains
and established the
Kotlin Foundation.
The foundation will
ensure that Kotlin
continues to advance rapidly,
remain free, and stay open.
To learn more about this
and other Kotlin news,
head on over to the post.
Asset Inventory is
now available in beta.
With it, you can get an org
wide snapshot of your inventory
for a wide variety of Google
Cloud Platform resources
and policies with
a single API call.
This can then be used
by automation tools
for monitoring, or
policy enforcement,
or be archived for
compliance auditing.
Example code is on the post.
We recently extended
the Gmail API
by bringing you new ways
to manage the delegate
settings of users in G Suite.
With Gmail delegation,
you can grant access
to a person's mailbox to another
person in their organization,
such as giving an
administrative assistant access
to an executive's mailbox.
Links to get started
are on the post.
The Go Project is
conducting research
to better understand which
companies are using Go
and how they are
using the language.
This questionnaire
will provide data
on how the Go language
and ecosystem can
improve to better serve
the needs of your company.
Please head on over to
the post before October 30
to take the seven-minute
questionnaire.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Dan Galpin for
"The Developer Show."
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
Hi.
I'm Dan Galpin for
"The Developer Show."
This is your week--
SPEAKER: Dan, you're going
to need a different shirt.